Thanks Chris for that question. The answer here is 57. Let's see how we got
that. So whenever I replace the variables with these variables, I have to
remember to use parentheses. So I'm going to substitute the values in. I have a
negative and then I have a cubed. I know that a equals negative 2. b is negative
1. We want to raise that to the c power and c equals 5. 5ac means 5 times a,
times c. So we have 5 times a, a is negative 2 and c is 5. Now we have to use
the order of operations to evaluate the expression.First we want to do. Any
operations that are inside parentheses, but there are none. So next I want to do
my exponents or my powers. Here the negative is inside the parentheses, so it's
negative 2 times negative 2 times negative 2, which gives me negative 8. When we
raise negative 1 to the fifth power, 5 is an odd number, which means the
answer's going to be negative. So negative 1 to the 5th power is simply negative
1. Remember, when we're doing order of operations, and we're doing
multiplication and division. We want to perform each operation in order from
left to right. So first I have negative 1 times negative 8, gives me positive 8.
I bring down the plus negative 1 and then I have negative 5 times negative 2.
That gives me positive 10. Positive 10 times 5 is positive 50. Now that I've
done all my multiplication and division, and I only have addition. I can do
those in order from left to right. So first I do 8 plus negative 1, which is 7.
And, 7 plus 50 is equal to 57.